hey lieben heutige ceos für die die es
eilig haben ihr dürft die wartezeit
nicht beachten aber die zubereitungszeit
geht wie bei diesem rezept so schnell
das glaubt ihr gar nicht und weil ich
mein pudding keksrezepte gut gefallen
und habe ich mir noch was einfallen
lassen und zwar diesmal mit banane und
auch mit einer super coolen optik und
nicht nennen es jetzt ganz einfach band
pudding rolle plötzlich doch worin oder
nein
ihr könnt mir nicht antworten da wir
könnten in die kommentare schreiben ob
der name kulissen kann ich ihnen noch
ändern im titel also wir starten jetzt
zuallererst mit den zutaten und zwar
benötigen wir kekse ja habe ich
vollkommen butterkekse genommen außerdem
milch zum trinken der kekse
die habe ich bananen und für den pudding
brauchen wir mit speisestärke bei kakao
und zucker
natürlich könnt ihr die letzten vier
zutaten wie ich euch gezeigt auch
austauschen da könnt ihr einfach ein
fertig schokoladenpudding nehme also
pulver zum anmischen habe ich nie da
deswegen mache ich mir jetzt selber und
zwar gebe ich jetzt die hälfte der milch
in einem topf aber noch nicht
einschalten so und zur anderen hälfte
geben wir jetzt die drei zutaten also
zucker oder kakao und speisestärke
[Musik]
sobald die masse dann klümpchen frei ist
können den herd einschalten und die
mischung erhitzen und sobald ihr merkt
sie steigt so langsam buch gibt ihr die
masse rein und rührt kräftig und sobald
es dann einmal aufkochen ist der pudding
fertig
[Musik]
der schoko pudding ist fertig und sie
hat den blick nur in eine andere
schüssel umgefüllt und ich ruhe auch
ständig also das problem ist wir den
jetzt stehen lässt eine halbe minute
schon dann bildet sich die haut und dann
müsst ihr die entfernen und dann ist das
verschwendung deshalb immer wieder hören
und nur so 23 minuten auslaufen lassen
und parallel mache ich hier weiter jetzt
kommen nämlich unsere tipps zum einsatz
ich habe dir weh gewalt vollkorn
butterkekse weil die mir einfach besser
schmecken
ihr könnt jetzt auch kakaobutter keks
oder ganz normale nehmen ganz wie ihr
möchtet und ich denke sie jetzt immer in
etwas milch und gebe sie dann auf meine
folie ich habe ganz einfach frisch alte
folie ausgelegt dann fangen wir jetzt
einfach an zu schichten
[Musik]
und die kekse tun ist immer nur eine
sekunde in die mädchen sind zwar noch
hart aber die werden nach dem auskühlen
richtig schön weich und sobald ihr das
dann erledigt habt also die erste lage
ist raus
genau was auch schon gerechnet super
wollte mich gerade waren 15 stimmt genau
parallel habe ich natürlich immer wieder
ungerührt damit sich keine haut bildet
könntet auch frischhaltefolie drauf tun
und jetzt nehmt ihr euch einfach ein
bisschen pudding aber nur so eine dünne
schicht und verstreicht es schon mal so
wer mit zwei lagen butterkekse und zwei
langen schokopudding als nächstes muss
er irgendwo die banane dazwischen passen
deswegen zeige ich euch wie wir das
jetzt machen das fange ich an mit der
dritten lage butterkekse setzte sie aber
nur links und rechts an also die mitte
die bleibt frei
[Musik]
sonst habe ich zwei weitere lang von den
butterkeksen auf die den kuchen trotte
das eigentlich torte sein wie sowas nein
auf dem kuchen gemacht jetzt will die
zuschauer jetzt machen wir die bananen
in die mitte einmal schälen nicht
wundern ich hab ihn mülleimer
ich weiß es nicht auf den boden und
jetzt rennt einfach genau in die mitte
gen ich teile das aber jetzt noch mal so
ein bisschen durch
[Musik]
wollen ihr altes schon als nächstes wird
die folie einmal zusammen geklappt so
dass wir ein dreieck erhalten und macht
euch keine sorgen das sieht nach einer
herausforderung aus ist aber eigentlich
total einfach so freuen uns noch mal
richtig schön so gemacht also lasst es
auf jeden fall in der frischhaltefolie
wir nehmen die gleich gemeinsam ab aber
erstmal müssen wir das gute stück kühlen
und zwar zwei stunden lang dann wird
alles richtig schön fest die butterkeks
zu werden weil man kommt nur bbq so und
den restlichen pudding gehen dürfte
jetzt nicht verlassen
den brauchen wir später nämlich noch für
die deko und darf jetzt ganz einfach
frischhaltefolie direkt auf die
oberfläche getan wenn sehen uns gleich
nach der kühl zeit wieder würdig kühl
zeit ist endlich um für mich der
schwierigste part hier einfach zu warten
ich bin sehr ungeduldig aber was soll
man machen jetzt ist alles wenigstens
schön fest und wir können die folie
entfernt und das geht auch sehr einfach
da brauche ich gar keine sorgen machen
damit unsere bannern rolle jetzt auch
noch richtig hübsch aussieht nehmen wir
uns wie gesagt den restlichen pudding
und streichen einmal rundherum den
kuchen ein
schon wieder fast worte sagen
[Musik]
so gibt es jetzt ein bisschen rustikal
eingestrichen und bei dem pudding ist
das jetzt so wenn ihr das glänzend haben
möchtet und weich dann müsste es sofort
verzehren wenn ihr wollt dass es schön
anzieht und dunkel wird und wieso mit
glasur richtig schön trocken wird dann
gibt es noch mal für ein paar stunden
den kühlschrank ich nehme mit der erste
versuche ich halt ziemlich sich länger
aus und ich dekoriere das ganze jetzt
noch mit pistazien diesen schirm grün
und geben noch mal so richtig schön
kontrast
[Musik]
wir lieben ja gesehen wie weit dieser
kuchen ist so lecker und ich werde jetzt
noch genießen ihr könnt natürlich
jegliche art von krieg zu nehmen wie ihr
möchtet
ich habe ich muss noch kurz einen cut
machen ich muss jetzt unbedingt einmal
probieren noch mal vor der kamera
unbedingt nachmachen wir dem nicht nach
zog dann habt ihr was die genauen
mengenangaben ich den und in der infobox
machen sie mit bei target muss ich zum
abschluss kommen abonniert main kanal
wenn ich nicht schon längst getan habt
und däumchen nach oben riss das video
gefaltet und kommentiert vielleicht was
er als leser sehen möchtet dann seid ihr
hoffentlich beim nächsten mal dabei auf
deals kitchen
[Musik]